from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between five guys in the uk and the us
this is food wars
burgers from the uk five guys come in
two sizes five guys in the u.s
also has two burger sizes firstly we
have the little which is just one patty
and the regular which is two patties
now our patties are supposed to be
lighter than the us patties and should
weigh 67 grams
we're going to weigh one and find out if
that's accurate
so this patty actually weighed 52 grams
which is 15 grams less than what we're
supposed to get
according to the u.s five guys website
they say that one of the patties
should weigh 94 grams or about 3.3
ounces
we will weigh a hamburger patty in the
us-5 guys
as a 52-53 grams
it looks like our patties weigh just
about the same as the ones in the uk
we're not sure if they measure it before
or after cooking maybe it's before and
then some of the liquid leaves as it
cooks
but either way not quite what we're
expecting this right here is a hot dog
from a us5 guys
and before i measure it
what in the heck is this
did you know this they cut the hot dog
in half
i hate that they cut this in half cursed
image
okay how long is this monstrosity six
and one-fourth inches
for the hot dog
so a hot dog from a uk five guys is
about six inches in length
and i like the burgers this has an
estimated weight and it should weigh 146
grams if the website's ingredients
information is correct but ours actually
weighs 154 grams so we're actually
getting more than expected
okay let's weigh this thing before i
throw it in the ocean
worry about a hair over 150.
okay i want to talk to one of the five
guys get me guy number three or four i
don't get i don't care
i demand to know what is going on with
these hot dogs
a five guys chocolate milkshake in the
u.s i believe it's 12 ounces
let's see what it actually is here
this one's a little bit more a little
bit more melted wait wait wait wait wait
wait
oh yeah that's way more than 12 buddy
that's way more than 12.
it is just over 450 milliliters
almost 16 ounces this is a milkshake
from a uk five guys we're going to
measure it to find out how much you get
oh yes i want it
now the uk portion size is advertised as
454 milliliters
we've got just over 400 here if we
scraped around the side we could
probably get a few more in there as well
now five guys in the uk is notorious for
overfilling its fry portions
we also get three sizes little regular
and large
we ordered all three and they came in
one bag and here's what we got
little fries regular fries
large fries and this is the rest of the
bag
now we're not sure which of these fries
belongs to which of these portions so
we're gonna try and figure it out
in the us we also have three sizes of
fries at the five guys
the small uh
the regular
the large and yes so
many more fries look at that so all in
all
five guys is very generous with the
fries
i mean i guess i'll start by filling
each cup
and then try and portion this into like
vague threes i guess
yes that sounds right i don't know if it
is but i'm just going to follow harry's
lead on this one
so this is roughly what we think would
go with each of the portions
now in the uk a regular fries is
supposed to weigh 414 grams
we're going to weigh the cut and then
also the extras to see if what you get
really is a bonus
or if it actually all adds up to the
supposed total
165. so first we'll do the scale right
so this is supposed to be 411 grams
let's see what we got
what is this 170 woof guys that's not
even close
so our regular cup of fries actually
only contained 165 grams which is less
than half of what you're supposed to get
we're gonna weigh the rest of the fries
to see if that makes up the difference
so even with all the bag fries which we
assigned to the regular portion
we're still only looking at 276 grams
which is well below the portion size
you're supposed to be getting for a
regular
excellent idea harry i will do the same
now we are up to
275 still now supposedly 411.
so it looks like we've been a bit short
changed on the fries because it was all
given to us in one big bag it's hard to
tell which portion came out small so
what we're going to do is add the little
fries to this one
get a total figure for all three
portions and then figure out how much
we've been shortchanged overall
so we've done the maths and between our
large regular and little fries
including the bag fries we only got 830
grams
however we were supposed to get 1220
grams
which means we've been shortchanged by
roughly a third here
frygate 2020 technically harry this is
frygate 2021
check the release schedule with the rest
of the bag fries the large
and the little so they gave us 851
grams of fries total they're supposed to
give us
1225. hey siri
850 is what percentage of 1225.
69 nice
so at least in our case it seems as if
the generosity of five guys has been a
bit overstated
maybe they just overfill smaller
containers so you kind of think you're
getting more than you should be
whereas in reality if you measure it all
you're actually maybe getting less
let's compare the prices of both five
guys and see who's getting the better
deal
okay usa this hamburger costs nine
dollars and twelve cents
that is way too much money for this
burger a hamburger from a uk five guys
will cost you six pounds ninety five
which is equivalent to 9.20
the prices do seem similar but it's
actually per gram 26
less in the us than it is in the uk
what about the fries well in the uk a
large prize is 5 pounds 25
which comes to six dollars and ninety
five cents
in the us our five guys large after tax
is seven dollars and six cents you must
be joking if you do the maths for the
fries
it turns out that the us is getting a
better deal but only fractionally you
guys get like one percent more value for
your money when it comes to the large
fries so
not too mad about that one a big draw is
that when you're in
five guys they have just crates
open with peanuts and while you're
waiting for your food you just scoop
some peanuts and just like
crack the shells up what do you even
mean so if you go in the store and you
wait you can eat like uh
you can peel and eat peanuts and throw
the shells on the floor
like it's a saloon in the 1800s who
cares especially if you're going there
to eat let me fill up in these cheap
peanuts before i get this ridiculously
priced food
compared to some of the places that
we've reviewed on this show before five
guys is a more expensive option but i
mean particularly in the uk
i don't feel too mad about paying a bit
more for a five guys than i might do for
only mcdonald's
it's just more of a treat but it does
feel a bit more exotic they've branded
themselves as a kind of like american
import americans know their way around a
burger sort of thing
so if i go i know that i'm getting
something of a little bit higher quality
than maybe a standard fast food place
even if the prices are gonna cost me
more
i hate five guys the hot dog is
ridiculous i don't care about peanuts
this stuff is way overpriced
forget it
let's take a look at the calories of the
five guys cheeseburger that says two
patties
two slices of cheese and a bun and the
total calories is 984.
what about a uk cheeseburger well this
one comes to 756 calories which is more
than 200 calories less than the us
burger the us burger doesn't just have
more calories either it's got pretty
much more of everything else it's got
more fat
saturate and sodium than a cheeseburger
in the uk
in the uk if they actually give you
what's advertised on the website a large
portion of fries is a hefty 1490
calories but despite that we still
somehow end up with less sodium
our large fine in the u.s is 1 314
calories i also want to point out our
fries come in lower than the uk
in terms of fat content as well as
saturates and finally we have the drinks
this chocolate shake out of five guys in
the us is 830 calories
a chocolate shake in the uk comes to
slightly more at 891 calories
so what if we combine all three into a
meal so a plain cheeseburger regular
fries and a chocolate shake from five
guys in the us
totals at 2767
calories yo dog also i think this is
about seventy dollars
the same meal in the uk well that comes
to a total of two 2769 calories
two calories more than in the us the
differences between the burger and the
fries effectively cancel each other out
[Music]
let's start with the basics here's
everything in a hamburger patty from a
uk5 guys
ground beef here in the u.s
our burger patty is made up of ground
beef
if you prefer to add cheese to your
burger here's what's in the cheese in
the uk
cheddar cheese water butter cheese
milk proteins whey powder emulsifying
salt trisodium citrate
natural cheese flavoring salt lactic
acid sorbic acid
beta carotene paprika extract and
sunflower lecithin
five guys cheese here in the us is made
up of milk
whey milk fat milk protein concentrate
salt
calcium phosphate sodium citrate whey
protein concentrate sodium phosphate
sorbic acid apocalyptental
what apocarotinol
aprocatarinol and that out enzymes
vitamin d3 and cheese cultures
the burger buns are also pretty similar
in the uk a burger bun is made with
wheat flour water sugar vegetable fat
milk dry yeast eggs sesame seeds
salt soy flour calcium carbonate and
spirit vinegar
the bun in the u.s is made up of water
salt sugar
vegetable shortening milk eggs bleached
bread flour
yeast and sesame seeds now you think
that the fries would be pretty similar
in the two countries and for the most
part you'd be right
in the uk the fries are made of potatoes
peanut oil and salt
the fries of the five guys in the us are
made from potatoes refined peanut oil
and salt now when they say refined
peanut oil apparently
the peanut oil in the uk is not refined
here in the us it is what that means is
they do something with distillation or
neutralization
i don't even know but the reason they do
it is to give it a better shelf life and
a more uniform taste
this has been the greasiest food wars
ever done
so they are very generous with peanut
oil and the fries and pretty much
everything else
there are a few things to watch out for
on the menu at five guys for example the
pickles in the u.s
in the u.s the pickles contain a food
coloring called yellow five or
tetrazine if this is added to foods in
the european union
they have to have a warning saying that
they might cause hyperactivity in
children
yes our pickles have a bunch of junk in
it so does the relish specifically it is
made up of cucumbers corn syrup water
high fructose corn syrup
vinegar salt xanthan gum 0.1
of sodium benzonate as a preservative
calcium chloride
alum natural flavors polysorbate 80
yellow number five and maltol
in our shortest exclusive section yet
here is everything you can only find on
the menu at a uk five guys
and here are all the exclusive five guys
menu items in the u.s
let's start with the burger there's only
one option in the uk that you won't be
able to find in the us
and that is hp source i won't go into
too much detail in case joe accuses me
of brits blaming again
but for those who don't know hp source
is like a the only customization in the
us that you can't get in the uk
is actually something that everyone in
the united states knows exactly what i'm
talking about
and that is a one steak sauce
it looks a lot like the hp brown sauce
but it is not it doesn't taste anything
like it
it is uh the most popular
steak subs
he won it's how steak is done
i don't know if it even exists outside
of the us the rest of our exclusive
options come as drinks
such as milkshakes we have a biscuit
shake which is flavoured with biscoff
biscuits which are those little caramel
flavored cookies which you get on the
side of a tea or coffee then we have
three dessert shake options which
are milkshakes flavored with things
which kind of combine to replicate
famous desserts
so here we have a millionaire shortbread
milkshake here we have a banoffee pie
milkshake
and here we have a strawberry cheesecake
milkshake
now for the last thing the only shake
you can get in the u.s you can't get in
the uk
is this is it oreo listen to me when i
say it let me finish before you start
typing
an oreo double stuff milkshake
yes you guys have the oreo shake there i
think you also have an oreo cream shake
there too
but this is the only oreo double stuff
shake if you don't have oreo double
stuff
in the uk they're what they sound like
oreos with twice as much
filling this is the last thing we're
shooting today and i've been waiting for
this
all day
holy this is so good guys i'm not
playing
this might have turned the tides on how
i feel about five guys i'm not kidding
this is so good i'm finishing this i
don't care how sick it makes me
i'm drinking it and last but by no means
least in the uk you can wash your
burgers down with
a range of beers
yeah well they don't serve beer at r5
guys but
i brought my own cheers my man
it is very warm it's a half a hot dog
that split it like i'm still like what
i'm like i'm shook
by that this is why people on the
internet now are like i think a hot dog
is a sandwich when you serve it like
that like
like with like the meat cut in half like
that so yeah it kind of looks but it's
not
it's a hot dog you don't cut it down the
middle like that
it's ridiculous